two of the world's biggest tech
companies are facing diverging fortunes
just one day after facebook parent
meta's valuation fell by a record 237
billion dollars amazon is on track to
gain almost as much in market value
thanks to a nearly 20 stock rally in
after-hours trading that's after the
e-commerce giant set its profit doubled
from a year earlier to 14.3 billion
dollars the earnings rise comes just as
amazon prepares to hike its prime
subscription prices in the u.s
amazon surge bucks a trend seen in the
wake of metas fall where a number of
tech stocks saw heavy losses
now let's get more on this from our
reporter rob watts who joins me in the
studio
so rob we've seen really uh
big big differences in the performances
of facebook amazon what's behind that
yeah it's a real tale of two tech giants
amazon has got its own problems you know
problems that are being seen by all
sorts of companies you know supply chain
problems and such and actually amazon is
also seeing its growth slowing you know
it did really well at the height of the
pandemic when people were locked in at
home and you know what they were doing
was just ordering offline and getting
stuff sent to them but since people have
been out about once again amazon started
to see that slow down but it's made up
for any pitfalls with really good
performances in other parts of its
business for example its ad sales have
risen by about a third during the last
quarter
what amazon does it allows brands to pay
extra so you can see their products
first when you search on amazon's
website it's also seen as cloud
computing business do very well that's
grown by 40
during the last quarter and that's
really one of the big engines of new
growth for amazon it's behind you know
netflix's website mcdonald's website
they're all storing their data on
amazon's servers so that's all making up
for the the real problems that we're
seeing at amazon in terms of its growth
slowing so amazon also was preparing to
hike the the subscription price for
prime what is driving that decision
well i mentioned the challenges that
amazon is facing and it's really trying
to spend its way out of those problems
for example there's a real recruitment
squeeze in the united states companies
are struggling to get people amazon's
laid its money down and it's been
offering signing on bonuses to try and
get people to come and work for it also
those supply chain problems that i'm
talking about i mean that delivering
goods to people
at the sort of pace that people expect
from amazon has been tricky and it's
been spending more on deliveries to try
and make up for that problem and um
to take on the extra costs that it's
facing it's now looking to its millions
of prime subscribers and it's increasing
prices just in the united states an
extra two dollars a month or an extra 20
dollars per year and it's hoping by
doing that that it can start to claw
back the extra money that it's having to
spend elsewhere and amazon's raised its
prices before it raised them four years
ago and the four years ago before that
it didn't see too big a drop off in
subscriptions as a result of that and
it's hoping that this time you know
overall it will pay off well investors
obviously seem quite confident in this
strategy with amazon basically on track
to gain a fortune today
facebook other tech companies not doing
as well does it still make sense to
refer to all of these companies as big
tech is there really a diverging
field here well i think you group big
tech at your peril and i think the
fortunes of meta and amazon over the
past two days have really shown that
it's the differences in how they operate
that makes the difference it gives one
of them a soaring share price and the
other one sees it absolutely plummeting
but we've had another good example of it
as well over the past couple of days so
snap which owns snapchat that messaging
service where the message disappears
after a certain amount of time well when
facebook posted these disappointing
results or rather meta did
shares in
snap also took a hit people thought well
if if it's bad news for facebook it's
probably bad news for snap as well their
social media but then snap came out with
its first ever quarterly profit and
after that it shares soared by 58
because it's it's it's different to
facebook it isn't facebook so in all the
areas where facebook's struggling snap
is seeing its users grow it's also not
getting the tick tock effect that
facebook's getting particularly in in
india where tick tock you know is banned
snap is growing really fast so that's an
example of how you can't group even
social media together and so you
certainly can't group all big tech
that's rob watts from uw venus thank you
so much for being here
you